Okay. So here's some practical matters, Michael. I mentioned
one of them before, and that is that mimic
does well with structure. When the optimal values that
you care about depend only on the structure, as
opposed to specific values, mimic tends to do pretty
well. By contrast Randomize hill climbing, genetic algorithms. These
other things that we've looked at before can sometimes
get confused by two different values that are both optima
but look very different from one another. Where it's the
structure that matters and not the actual values. So, the chain
example before where you had alternating values as one of those
cases where it's easy for randomized algorithms that only look for
point values to get confused. 'because their basically being drawn
in multiple directions at once. The quiz also brought up another
point which is worth mentioning here was that mimic and with
anything that tries to do this kind of search through probability
[UNKNOWN] is that it's an issue of representing everything.
That is it's not enough just to be able to
represent a probability distribution of the [UNKNOWN]. You really
want to be able to represent everything in between as
you move through probability space toward your answer. This
is the universal symbol for moving through probability space. You
don't just want to represent here at the end and
here at the beginning which is pretty easy because uniform
distribution, but can you represent this point? Can you represent this point?
And if you can't are you going to end up getting stuck. And
actually turns out that mimic can get stuck in local optimal though
it typically does not optima because you get randomize your search for optima.
>> Hm. I see.
>> But the problem of local optima is still a problem of local
optima. Now, when I say something like you get randomized restarts for free,
I'm actually cheating a little bit and hiding something which is
a little bit more important, which is what you really get
for free is probability theory. So there's a hundred, literally, hundreds
of years of work on how to think about representing probability distributions
and what you can do with them and there are terms
like important sampling and rejection sampling And all these kinds of
tools that we have for representing probability distributions that you ca
actually inherit with something like Mimic for dealing with these painful cases
where you might not be able to represent distributions.
>> But the single most important thing to me about Mimic or what to get out
of here is that representing structure does matter.
But you pay a price. And that price
basically boils down to, time. So the question
we might ask ourselves, is, what is the
sort of practical time complexity of mimic? And,
it really boils down to something very simple.
Let me just share a fact with you Michael. Okay. I
have run this algorithm on many, many, many examples and I've
compared it to simulated [INAUDIBLE].
I've compared it to [INAUDIBLE] algorithms.
I've compared it to randomized hill climbing. And it works pretty
well for the sorts of examples I've come up with. And
here's a little fact that I just want to give you.
Mimic tends to run orders of magnitude fewer iterations. And I'm
not exaggerating here; I mean that if I run Simulated Annealing,
it might take 100,000 iterations for something like
Simulated Annealing, but for Mimic, it might take only
a hundred. And this is consistently true, so
it turns out that that's not good enough. It
turns out that the fact that Mimic can
do something in three, four, five, six, seven orders
of magnitude fewer iterations Is it an argument
for always using it? Can you imagine one now?
>> because it might give a worse answer?
>> Well, in practice it doesn't. So, these are
cases where both simulated [UNKNOWN] and mimic, or randomized hill
climbing or genetic algorithms actually eventually do find the answer.
Mimic just finds it in orders of magnitude, fewer iterations.
>> But you're counting iterations.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You didn't control for the fact that Different
algorithms, can take different times for a single iteration.
>> That's exactly right. So, what do you think?
If I were to compare simulated annealing to mimic,
which do you think take, the, takes more time for any given iteration?
>> Well simulated annealing just does this little tiny
step, right? It like, computes a bunch of neighbors
and then does a probability comparrison, and then, takes
a step. Mimic is drawing this sample, estimating a
bunch of parameters, then yeah. I guess the other
way around. It's drawing from a distribution. It's computing
which things are say above the median performance, and
then it's re-estimating a new distribution. And then that's
the end of the iteration. Depending on how many samples
it takes to do that, it's, it could take a
very long time, and in particular, it's going to always be
a lot more samples than what simulated annealing is doing.
>> Almost certainly. So, when would you think that MIMIC would still be worth
using in a case like that, where we know that we can get to the
answer, but simulated annealing will take orders
of magnitude more iterations, MIMIC will take
fewer iterations? So when would it still be worth it to take the one with
fewer iterations even though east, each iteration is
expensive? Prints algorithm, quadratic this that and the other.
>> Oh yeah, grab at that part, hm.